[Music]
so okay so we've got your feelings on
Trump I think I think they're clear
right yeah well I have I've been trying
to moderate them today unless you know
the pide just wrote a piece in The New
Yorker today on the nuclear threat and
and to be more serious
his misunderstanding of the fact that
nuclear weapons are not meant to be used
yeah and in fact as I pointed out it
demonstrates a lot of our of the
illogical nature of our nuclear policy
but when he says if you you know if we
build them why can't we use them that
anyone who's thought about it realizes
you can't you can't use them in any
strategic way and yeah and so it's and
if he wants to encourage other countries
to build them he misunderstands the
whole point of proliferation and those
things are serious they're not you know
we can't laugh over that stuff yeah so I
really tried and I think most people
that watch this show I really tried to
be fair to him and and and whatever yeah
so when he's talked about the nuclear
stuff and they'll say something like you
know Japan should have nukes so that
they could defend them potentially from
China it seems to me that there's some
grain of truth in the in the concept of
that that that we shouldn't have to feel
like we have to do defend Japan well but
you're saying it really throws off every
sort of precept of how all these nations
have well it proves off the precept of
really what we should be trying to do
with nuclear weapons which we isn't
talked up enough today which is we want
to reduce the number of nuclear weapons
of the world because there's really no
good use for the right eye and we built
up this incredible stash of nuclear
weapons because of the Cold War and we
have this a policy of mutually assured
destruction so we had to have enough to
ensure the total annihilation of the
Soviet Union when they were the Soviet
Union and that's okay but we then you
know even at the time of Nixon we signed
a non-proliferation treaty most people
think the non-proliferation treaty and
this is this is it's so typical of the
u.s. yeah is designed to say no one
should have nuclear weapons but us
and that's not what it's about yeah it's
trying to say we don't want to have
nuclear weapons to spread but the other
thing that the nuclear nations agreed to
in the non-proliferation treaty
what's the disarm and so we have an
obligation we are violating the
non-proliferation treaty today in the
this country as much as North Korea
maybe by trying to get nuclear weapons
or getting new carbons or Iran if which
happily they haven't stopped from
getting them for the moment yeah because
we are not making an open effort at its
arm and Obama who whose heart was
certainly the right place he said you
know we we should the world should
should get rid of nuclear weapons and
initially the the the his administration
actually did an inter an agreement with
the Soviet Union with the Russia to
reduce the number of arms but we still
have way too many we still have a
thousand nuclear weapons on hair-trigger
alert which means they can be launched
instantaneously if if there's a warning
of an attack whether the warning is real
or not the president only has a few
minutes to decide that is not necessary
in the modern world and also
unfortunately and I'm happy to see that
that Hillary Clinton seems to be against
it we are barking on a one trillion
dollar modernization of the nuclear
weapons fleet which is only reasonable
if we plan to keep our nuclear weapons
level at what it is if we say no you
know eventually we want to reduce them
we don't have to spend that much money
trying to maintain the arsenal we now
have and so it's interesting to me to
see that the nuclear issue which over
time has been has raised and lowered and
importance the public doesn't seem to
think about it but it is still the major
threat the major existential threat to
civilization and and we as a country are
not doing enough and it is true at the
same time we're probably going to this
more than you wanted yeah no no it's
true that that Russia is getting more
worrisome than they were afford that the
saber-rattling the arguments about
nuclear weapons are much worse now under
Putin in the last few years and they
were so there's some concerns in that
regard but but we could you take
unilateral steps which would lead us in
the right direction right so even if
Russia was 10 times worse than you might
yeah it is if we add half of our
stockpile it would still be more than
enough to destroy we had a tenth of our
so if we had a tenth of our stockpile we
we could still not only annihilate the
Soviet Union but essentially create
enough mess to destroy the world
right and
it we we need to we need to realize that
fact and and and realize that we can as
I say unilateral actions are often
responded to for example another area
where we spend money that we it's a wet
wait wasted time for the most part is
missile defense when one of things I
love is that George Bush claimed that
they were gonna have a missile defense
system ready in 2004 he was during the
election and and of course turned out
that most fifty percent of the American
public thought we already had one yeah
and as they are at the time what they
should say is we already have one there
we go because because they're just as
effective as this system that doesn't
work but it doesn't cost a hundred
billion dollars so it's a lot less
expensive and and it it serves the same
effect so how much of this though is
just that a huge percentage of our
economy is tied into the military it is
but you know though but what you're
hearing in the president the election is
we're not spending enough and that's
what's scary what we need to do is spend
rationally people say that for a long
time you know we spend almost a trillion
dollars on defense every year and the
question is we have to look and say what
are we need look it's not as if we can
disarm as a nation completely in all
ways the world is a dangerous place but
the question is do we need to spend that
kind of money and the answer I think for
many people is we could spend less more
effectively do you think there's any
situation where ethically we could use
nukes I mean if let's say because I
don't think it's going to be through a
nation-state but let's say they you know
somebody got a dirty bomb in here and
blew up Times Square so the question is
what do you I think the answer generally
is no nuclear weapons right now are
useful for deterrence to stop other
people from doing things but it is you
hit an interesting point that that when
might you use them and the cont what
many people may not realize is that the
country has no most people think the US
has in no first use policy namely we
would never be the first ones using we
don't write that because we said well
what if not sewing me uses nuclear
weapons but what if someone launches
biological weapons you know shouldn't we
a lot be allowed to nuke them or what if
someone nukes South Korea shouldn't
we've allowed to nuke in response and so
these are questions that you can debate
but
on the whole the question is what what
do you gain versus conventional forces
and we you know other than act of anger
right if what act has already been done
yeah yeah yeah so the question is what
do you the idea should be to stop that
in the future mm-hmm
not and and inevitably the problem is
that under many scenarios once you start
using nuclear weapons the it proliferate
sand and what's been pointed out by a
bunch of physicists even about ten years
ago you may remember nuclear winter with
Carl Sagan and that there was that was
sort of discredited a little bit but in
fact even at a limited nuclear war say
between Indian Pakistan of fifty or
hundred weapons which may sound like a
lot but it's the kind of thing you might
expect in a would it could work would
would raise enough basically dust in the
atmosphere to for a decade effect
agriculture ultimately perhaps killing a
billion people through starvation so
there's no such thing as a limited
nuclear war and it and everyone
including the right wing guys like
George Shultz and Henry Kissinger came
up a bunch years ago and said we need to
basically work towards a nuclear free
world because as long as we have nuclear
weapons we're all at risk so how do you
untie that then from the legitimate
parts of deterrence if your argument is
that deterrence is an important piece of
a strategy because might be by having
deterrence you don't necessarily have to
fight a ground war how do you untie
those well for example well how many we
can ask right now how many nuclear
weapons you need to deter a an aggressor
and it says you certainly don't need we
the United States has five thousand so
view the Russia Russia excuse me I grew
up in the Soviet Union's thank you for
getting what here it is yeah yeah I know
I know it exactly better be the Russia
has Russia has another five thousand
that's you know we don't need five
thousand weapons to deter you know 100
nuclear weapons would be more than
enough to destroy basically any country
and and dramatically affect the world so
maybe we can immediately go down to
wonder weapons nobody a difference then
ultimately for someone that's hearing
you and saying well if we haven't but
we're not using what's the difference
whether we have five thousand well it's
it to maintain a fleet of five thousand
weapons including the infrastructure
requires an incredible amount of money
so that
alone in practice one trillion-dollar
modernization gives you an example of
the infrastructure costs so their
economic costs as well as security costs
and if we decided rationally you know
what it's better to you know it's like
if you have ten cars it cost you a lot
more money to maintain them than if you
have one it's not just the cost of the
cars yeah so as a theoretical physicist
when you talk about all of this stuff
you you have an insight into how things
actually work that the average person
doesn't have do you worry that you'll
ever stumble upon something or you know
somehow accidentally or maybe
intentionally you find something and
then realize how it could be turned into
something horrific I mean that's like
the big apocalypse oh I see no happily
what I'm always pleased to say that what
I work on has no practical significance
whatsoever I heard you say that
everybody but but I worry about the
origins in history of the universe and
and and you know you can never of course
the great thing about science is you
never know what's gonna be discovered or
what the implication so that I guess
what if you had to pick one area that
had less direct practical significance
you know it'd be hard to find one that
more than mine which worries where I try
and understand how the universe began
and how its gonna in and these these
questions are incredibly important for
us culturally but the but the kind of
new physics that we try and develop and
understand affects the universe on
scales that really are divorced from
human scales directly obviously they
they relate to what the reason you know
how we got here my new book which I will
plug called the greatest story ever told
so far
yeah the subtitle March 27 yeah March
2017 is and it's but the subtitle is
called why are we here
yeah and and ultimately we want to
understand those questions and
unfortunately religion tries to protect
its user for those questions I want to
point out how science can dress them so
their fundamental sort of cultural
questions but but I like to say although
it's pretentious because I don't want to
meet comparison but my work is or and
the work by people like me is as useful
as a Mozart symphony I mean it's it's
best at its best it could be as useful
as a Mozart symphony it enhances the
cultural experience of being human
so I'm happily I'm not as worried about
that but on the other hand what we need
to do is is
for there's an old expression I think
from pastor but it could be from later
on and I've tried to track it out but
fortune favors the prepared mind and
what we need to do or think about what
the possibilities are so we're prepared
to act and we can't be prepared to act
if we put our heads in the sand so we
can say oh we should never you know do
genetic engineering but it's happening
we we so we can talk about artificial
intelligence and say we need to we need
to stop that but it's not going to be
stopped what we need to do or think
about the possibilities and that's one
of the reasons why the origins project I
run it it's you is so for me so exciting
because we try to bring scientists
together to look at forefront questions
but then we have public events where
3,000 people attend and listen and the
point is to and then you know you can't
have a good democracy without an
informed population and and so to try
and raise these questions and get people
to think about the possibilities are
will allow us to be better prepared for
for surprising possibilities in the
future because we don't know where the
future lies and I often say and I said
it on a film recently that I'm not if
you someone tells you they're a futurist
in my mind that's when you stop
listening I try not to make predictions
about anything other than like two
trillion years in the future that's a
what do you call that as a super future
well yeah first of all no one will be
around to test it and it's much easier
but but but we don't discoveries are
called discoveries because they're
surprises but we can try and at least
anticipate the set of possibilities so
it'll be a little less surprised and all
of us can do that and that's why you
know you say I'm a scientist and I have
access it's true I have access to some
information people don't normally have
access to but the process of science we
can all be at least have a perspective
of what's happening and that's why it's
important that's why I spend time in in
the my with my public hat trying to
trying to explain and explore science
for the public not just because it's
interesting and exciting and it is it's
fun and people are fascinated by it but
because hopefully it'll be useful when
people try and confront the challenges
of the 21st century all right so I want
to spend the rest of this talking about
your actual work okay origins and stuff
I guess but my last question on this
part I don't I have no agenda but I know
you don't you made it
clear which I love that so but my last
part goes to your public happy because
clearly you're willing to talk about
politics you're willing to you know
speak about things freely and and as you
emailed me I'd have no no agenda or
anything do you ever fear that that will
have a professional cost just by saying
things I already had it does all the
time but I suppose someone said no I
if I feared about that I would have
stopped a long time ago I guess look I
think there's not a day goes by that I
don't realize I'm fortunate in a way
that people for one reason or another
want to listen to me or at least I have
a public profile and therefore I have a
responsibility it seems to me to use
that profile responsibly and that means
of course to try and and and and and
popularize science in a way but also to
try and do what I can to to have an
impact so in some sense you know it goes
hand in hand with what I said to you
about my work my work has no practical
significance whatsoever but I'm but as a
human being I'm very political I'm very
interested in what's going on and
therefore in some sense maybe I make up
for the fact that my work has no
usefulness by taking advantage of my
public profile to try and and do useful
things and one of the useful things can
try and be least to provoke people to
think about these things and so that's
what I do
[Music]
you
[Music]